and he's only going to do I introduce a
few words for you right if a line passes
through a circle I hope it passes
through and it just slices across
something like this in fact looking to
all draw this okay if I learn slices
through a circle it's called a secant
secret sec amt if it slices through an
intersection circumference twice okay
now what I'm going to do is I want to
think about what happens if the secant
rather than intersecting twice if I move
it lower lower little until such a time
that it intersects only once it then
gets a special name what's it called a
tangent right we're going to draw it
eventually right well we'll get there in
a second so what if you know what
happens is this secant becomes closer
and closer to a tangent to understand
what I'm looking at I'm thinking in
particular about if I connect these two
radii here okay let's do a bit of
labeling here stupid lately it's
conventional to call the center of the
circle oh and then we've got these two
points on the circumference where our
secant intersects with our circle okay
so no call those two points of
intersection are going to call them p
and q and so that we can also refer to
our secret in a beautiful way and then
call the ends of the seekers the secant
a and B okay so I've see can a be cuts
the circle F P and Q so far so good okay
one last piece even though all this is
lines what I'm actually interested in
here and the result i'm going to go
towards is an angle ok so I'm going to
label this angle up here I'm just going
to call it theta okay quality none and
now let's get to work on this diagram
okay I'm after what I'm going to get
towards is what is this angle OPA over
here that's what I'm going to try
find out if not doesn't take too much
work to get there before we get to that
angle that's the egg you outside the
triangle the exterior angle so it makes
sense to think about the interior angles
okay now remember we drew Opie and oq
their radii so that means that they are
equal to each other so if you've got
isosceles triangle you agree with that
so if i can find out what each of these
are then i can find out what opa or apo
rubber is ok so if I just do the angles
of the triangle here noticing that is
isosceles I can say opaque you write
plus this angle here which is the same
as 0 PQ those two angles if I add them
to feed our that's the whole triangle
right that's a whole triangle so they
add up to their dads away right angle
summer triangle ok don't worry too much
about the reason the move I just want to
establish this result so you can see it
ok so now it doesn't take too much to
tidy this up I've got two lots of opq on
the left-hand side two of them and if i
drag over that theater to the other side
i've got 1 a minus theta agreed so
therefore i can just divide both sides
by 2 and that gives me this ok so now i
have a value for this interior angle
what I'm really after is the exterior
angle yeah ok so how would I work that
out I can take that exterior angle add
it to my interior angle and because
they're on a straight line they should
equal one ain't it good ok so let's just
tidy this up a p.o plus 90 minus theta
on to drop datum ok and if I make a p.o
the subject what do I get over here on
the right hand side after I even roll
out 180 I'll take away 90 which leaves
me with is IT right and then I will
because I want to add Theodora 2 to both
sides to get rid of it over the left
I'll have my agrees plus the or two does
that make sense
somehow that's the angle hours after I'm
going to pop that on to my diagram 90
degrees plus theatre on to and because
of the symmetry of this thing you've
also got it over here now you degrees
plus theta on to you could rehearse
exactly the same thing but instead of
A's and peas you have bees accuse okay
okay now we are going to think about
what happens to this secret as it gets
closer and closer to a tangent okay so
for example let's draw the same diagram
down but imagine if we drop down a bee
that's see if we dropped it down lower
okay so for example something like this
okay if a bee is still a secret but it
is further away from the center of the
circle I've still got much the same
configuration okay here are my points of
intersection okay how would you describe
the difference between scenario one is
scenario to how would you articulate it
apart from the fact that the secrets
gone further away what other things do
you notice yeah I get good so before I
had this really wide angle here was
obtuse right and now as you said it's
getting smaller so so much smaller in
fact that for this I've got an acute
angle in them okay so this angle theta
is getting smaller it's getting smaller
okay but all of the things we said
before are still true they're still true
um this angle over here exterior is
still 90 plus feed on to write in terms
of structure nothing has changed right
it still is still the same okay so now
here's what we're going to do we're
going to take the limit of this
situation as P and Q come together
because that's what then do it right you
see they're getting closer and closer
together okay in fact we can make them
go inside right here's a centaur if this
moon is all the way down so that you
have tangent right by the way tangent
there's a that's there's a latin-based
to that work we get another word in our
english language from the same root as
tensions they don't know what would we
get from a tangible which means
something you can touch right a tangent
is just touching the circle rather than
slicing through it okay enter tanger now
where a P and Q in this diagram they're
both they're both right there they're
both sitting on top of each other yeah
so there's p and q I still got a B over
here okay now remember you told me go
from stereo one to two feet are went for
a wide to narrow where's theta here it's
a bit this is a bit trickier this is why
limits are tricky idea feet are is right
in there provide it's between its but
it's p oq' a way you could say it is
that theta is zero I mean oh that's kind
of bigness because there's no angle
there but if there were an eagle it'll
be 0 but i still haven't changed like
arrangement of this situation right so
this angle here apo apo AP own right
it's 90 degrees plus feet Iran to but
what's theta n 0 so what's the single it
even looks like that doesn't it okay not
only can you argue it for the fact that
it has to be just 90 because theta has
gone towards zero okay but we could also
say hey look these two angles here we
established in the same angle it's a
symmetrical diagram right the only way
you can have two symmetrical diagrams
suit symmetric angles i should say that
a sitting on a straight line is that
both of them of course must be 90
degrees to agree with that so he says
okay so therefore my conclusion out of
this this is the property that gets
their numbers in this situation to you
the tangent which we've drawn as Amy the
tangent is perpendicular perpendicular
to what how would you describe this like
you
it's the it's the radius to the radius
but it's not just any rate it's a circle
it's an infinite number of radiuses
radio I hear a song right which have
nothing to do with my actual taejun
right so they're not just perfectly go
to the radius then perpendicular to the
radius and the point of contact that
point which we've called P or Q if you
like I